comment aller j'en peux plus j'en ai ras
le cul là du coup finement bordel comme
toute la france comme toute la planète
aujourd'hui vidéo mais gueule j'ai
préparé des petites scènes qui sont
scandaleuses vu qu'on est confiné mais
qui vont nous faire du bien parce que
c'est celle font comme s'il n'y avait
pas de confinement
là par exemple chez mme table d'un
restaurant en face de moi se trouvera
quelqu'un sur ma gueule on va prêtant
des touristes hors ensemble autour d'un
bon petit dîner et c'est grave là le
mental brigden il arrive à grands pas
j'ai l'impression allez c'est parti et
installe toi tu veux quoi tu fais un
truc tu vas bien et je vais bien du
parlement se fait du foie gras
directement ça me saoule est bien la
toile et coquette comme toujours c'est
quoi la feuille bas du compte sur les
changes mais départ au salut tu fais car
en chine hausse et au vivre ainsi toi
c'est toi je te prends quoi je sais
comment me qua non pas possible achetez
vite non la dr faust au cap et tu veux
quoi franchement ouais alors là je suis
là je ne dis pas tu as là dessus et
franchement elle s est pas le premier
qui dit un truc de riches dallas j'ai eu
droit au foie gras bientôt on va me
sortir le caviar c'est incroyable ça ne
veut semaine bien sortie de conflit de
moins en moins bien mais arrêtez de
chercher du coup parce que voilà mes
rêves et je la trouvais donc après moi
je t'attends pas à si je t'attends si tu
hurles je t'entends
je tente en mai 2 mégas loin et un
aspirateur maintenant on va résoudre ça
temps je peux t'aider il faut que tu me
donnes les codes de ta carte bleue juste
et je peux t'aider à les indus pas bhl
ah non je t'attends tu m'entends oui on
a réussi allez maintenant tu me passes
les codes de ta carte bleue
tu peux me passer les tiens je pense que
ça va être plus utile c'est possible
sinon ça va commencer tranquille tout va
bien et toi moi j'ai fait des bracelets
je peux voir des bracelets brésiliens
comme ça oh [ __ ] ok quand j'étais au
collège toucher plus quand j'avais vu ça
c'était stylet mais c'est l'eau entrait
quant à choper le truc ça va là tu te
mets à nous prendre de haut attention
non mais pas d'idées
bah écoutes je te souhaite un très bon
confinement là à tous ici et je te
laisse payer la note je me casse tu paie
la note voilà ce chao qui s'allument
elle a dit oui à les gentils je te sers
quoi tu veux quoi
kaiku je viens une petit castel raid une
caste je sais pas c'est quoi tu sais pas
ce que tu es une caste au raid
non ceux des meilleures bières attendant
tu me fais découvert un truc c'est bien
comme ça on n'influence tout le monde à
boire de l'alcool c'est parcequ'elle
exemple vous renvoie aux jeunes là haut
a fallu vraiment je te dise que en fait
j'étais en prépa un moment dans ma vie
est en fait tu m'as trouvé des vidéos ça
m'a vraiment genre je vais aller
jusqu'au bout du truc trop bien je sais
que j'ai eu des échos comme quoi que
c'était hyper accord est intense et tout
mais tant mieux si j'ai pu t'aider dans
ça et aussi je voudrais dire merci pour
tous les messages positifs que tu fais
passer genre je m'appelle jules chez une
personne trans tu vois dans la
communauté on t'aime beaucoup parce que
genre tu fais vraiment pas céder trop
bon message était toujours dans
l'acceptation des autres et
l'acceptation de soi et d'un message
positif et du coup je remercie voilà où
baba c'est à vous c'est vous qui m'avez
éduquer sur tout ça c 'est pas il n'est
du tout bah écoutes je t'embrasse et
puis courage pour le confinement quoi
l'accusé est plein de bonnes choses à
toi ben merci merci beaucoup et continue
pas de souci merci pour la force bisous
salue ce coup si tu es fan de l'om toi
j'ai l'impression non pas du tout il est
impassible
ça fait du bien là de voir des humains
sur mega le trouve pas ça fait trop
subir à chaque fois que je rentre comme
hegel il ya plein de gens il disputa
j'ai croisé trop de gens sympas avant
tombé sur toi oui mais c'est ça d'avoir
la meilleure des communes qui se disent
voilà qu'on lui a pas parlé de sujets
qui fâchent on va parler de sujets qui
fâchent écoute tu vas découvrir la
prochaine scène en avant première
attends faut que je me place bien est ce
que est ce qu on a l'impression que je
joue avec mon enfant
ouais a atteint réaction je juge que
c'est pas si où cette scène qu'est ce
qui est bizarre je joue avec mon enfant
pourquoi tu nous regardes non mais pas
de soutien s'est permise actu nouveau
fixe c'était très long ce moment au la
vache ça va les gars ont passé un bon
confinement servant nous sommes dans le
jury vous êtes en algérie actuellement
oui le pick up aux algériens ils obligés
suit la pensée
vous êtes en confinement pas du coup
là-bas ou et honte nous sommes en
confinement aussi ok d'accord et bien
gros big up à vous les gars beaucoup ont
finement à vous merci
désolé ferros et bisous soutient les
gars ben arrête déterminera si toi
j'espère que c'est une blague je te vois
pas déjà mais ce coup ci tu as fait peur
merci
waouh je jouais confessait tu me crie
dessus
non c'est une blague sine die tu m'as
fait peur en plus [ __ ] c'est à qui tu
es toi qui fais pas ta parler d'entamer
la c1 c'est un prêt ou c'est réellement
devrait hausser un peu des deux vous
êtes confinés ensemble
oui c'est ma copine on en confinement si
tout se passe bien vous foutez sur la
gueule tous les jours en fait je peux
encore mieux
un peu des deux peut te regarde par le
switch vers deux heures du matin après
ça mon profil je suis désolé mais je le
dis merci mieux que toi c'est tout bas
fait pas des poses toi tu vas te faire
[ __ ] faut pas faire des pouces titouan
des terres moi ça fait vingt minutes là
c'est une blague ôtez en fait ce tome
avec quelqu'un je veux dire bonjour
comment ça va la tête la tête ça devient
même ça c'est tout c'était à moi c'est
non merci qui a dit s'être au café non
ah ben je te remercie j'ai travaillé
j'ai dû détourner sur sable de merde à
vous voyez là est ce que je peux vous
montrer la prochaine scène vous me dîtes
si elle est bien faite à temps cette
frange non voilà on s'occupe comme on
peut pour le conflit dont je veux vous
dire ça depuis l'origine en croire des
[Musique]
imagine on croise des noms je veux
savoir ce lundi on y voit des gens comme
avant dans la vie de winnie
c'est drôle que quelqu'un
mon cher le kilo à mon cher ludovic in
allons prendre autant [ __ ] ça aurait
été beau mec j'ai fait une petite
chanson je chantais tout le monde de ce
type et j'ai adoré le jeu restera
concerts gratuits et les gens ce qu'ils
paient ah oui j'ai fait j'adore lyon qui
skie pour voir leur lanceur préféré toi
et ils m'ont tout ce qui touche aux
belges en boîte à chansons je te jure je
te skip pas moi c'est ce que je faisais
ce que je sais que je peux chanter
j'adore les gens qui ce qui passe était
mais ce n'est pas une chanson s'arrête
juge pas ok c'est vrai je me suis un peu
emporté je suis désolé at envie voir nos
voisins petit ami à moi qui
pratiqueraient mais eux n'ont ainsi un
fixe non mais attendez
bon alors ouais alors là c'est squeeze
pour de rien qu'est ce t'en ces
questions c'est bon je te vois je te
vois parler en fait souhaiter yeux donc
sûr que c'est un bon argument c'est un
bon argument
quoi d'autre quoi d'autre ou d'un coup
tu ta voix peut-être petites habitudes
aussi à faire des fonds verts rigolo
mais vous êtes vous êtes en quête
effectivement je suis je suis inspecteur
très grave vous avez crié ma couverture
dans quel département de la police
je peux pas vous dire c'est le
confinement mais il faut quand même
rester professionnel bien jouer on va
voir si vous êtes un vrai inspecteurs
attention qu'elle livre suis-je en train
de lire il n'y a pas de titre sur
internet
est-ce que je peux passer dans une vidéo
où des petits groupes sont très bons il
faut que tu m'aides certain moment une
seconde au montage ok ok danse par le
club à tout à quelques mots non non mais
non mais j'ai appris que ma profession
je suis coups bas ce tuer c'est trop
nous prennons tenait en quelle année
2006 2006 c'était quoi bon alors
attendre j'ai première lettre a à alex
et alexandre nom arthur non attends me
dis pas je vais trouver non mais non non
non c'est non c'est vrai si on avec mes
potos mois une bière s'était infiltrée
au fbi a eu quoi la tatouée tiré d'un
coup tu as que je vais montrer ma pote
c'est plus que je téléphone eric hazan
elle est là et lola potes que c'est vrai
mais tu te fais la gueule mais en fait
j'étais ami j'étais déguisée en garçon
pris avant je disais aux gens est ce que
ça passe
est-ce que je suis un garçon ça passait
vraiment pas au coeur de nos cadavres
ont réussi l'effet escompté
aucun de nous deux anaëlle armand non je
vais trouver
tiens tiens tiens tiens qui voyagent qui
est en jeu qui dérange qui voyage qui
vous tu as gagné
je sais je sais j'ai tous mes antoine
[Musique]
mais non à la tienne fait au nom de
férule attend laquelle celui-ci a pris
le dessus sur toi moi c'est pour bientôt
nathan et j'ai pas de calvi si tu veux
tu peux pas jouer là dessus t'as pas de
calvitie non choix de calvitie chez
malades
omar bongo vrai web pour de vrai en
excuse moi man mon dieu j'ai fait écoute
moi bien c'est la gaffe de ma vie mais
je suis désolé je vais pas grave tu as
quoi dit moi puisque j'ai vécu des
choses aussi à propos de ça avec une ex
ex
moi j'ai un sarcome d'ewing c'est un
cancer des os et des tissus mous
d'accord été traités en ce moment je
suis en rémission depuis 17 mois bravo
bravo kerrouchi kotor au butin était en
rémission depuis 17 mois incroyable
huawei 6 7 mois et du coup tu as des
contrôles fréquents pour pour voir si ça
reprend et pour les deux mois tous les
deux mois et pour le moment aucune trace
way a le plus dur est derrière du coup
pour le moment un mec je suis content
pour tard émission ça me fait vraiment
plaisir
ça me fait cool tu fais pas pour
t'occuper dans le confinement
ben j'ai appris à monter en fait et je
raconte mon histoire sur youtube un peu
tu vois je fais des vidéos et j'essaye
de parler un peu de buzz de ce qui
m'arrive en fait mon histoire trop bien
c'est quoi la chaîne un homme fort je
profite du confit nantes pour me lancer
un peu sur you tube tu vois j'ai rien à
faire je fais rien de mes journées donc
c'est trop mais un mec de faire ça c'est
je pense que tu va aider beaucoup de
gens en fait en faisant ça c'est
vraiment une bonne idée mais et ben qui
vient continu des vidéos mec là je
passais trop bien franchement ce droit
de faire ça merci a bientot et encore
désolé
ah et bien nous voici à la fin de cette
vidéo mais gueule c'était trop cool de
croiser des gens ses pairs concepteurs
de confinement en fait déjà
habituellement ça fait trop plaisir
quand on fait ses vidéos là mais là ne
parlant et nous voyant quasiment aucun
humain ça fait genre trop du bien
c'était vraiment cool merci à tous ceux
du cou qui sont venus sur omegle compris
le temps de me chercher de me parler de
vous montrer ce qu'ils ont fait c'était
très cool
bon courage pour la suite du confinement
et puis on va finir sur la fameuse
switcher effectué je suis plus heureux
et ça m'a épuisé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]